interesting pick
very interesting pick is he is he
already free rolling with his uh extra
life that's an interesting choice
so of course you know mob has to win two
first to threes to win this
uh which does give your opponent uh and
winners more time to to play around with
ideas to try things out
and uh he's picking josie straight from
the off
i do think he is taking liberties with
his extra life
um we saw kanemitsu the whole way except
for that one time he picked ling it
didn't work out
um i do think he's probably taking
liberty to that extra life
um i think i'm going to try jersey see
how that works
so i mean winning a game with josie with
a the character isn't your main is a is
a big statement
nice block on the wall bongos
nice patience yeah very hard for mob to
get in right now and they're the big
superman punch
punch the gut
nice start here by bombing
nice punish i think you have up to 14 or
15 frames to punish uh the war bombers
before switch one will punish you
for the count of hit
[Music]
nice g clef cannon very nice
finishes it gets caught counter hit
though this will hurt a lot
yeah
mix up rage drive spent cd2 not the best
punish but downpour one he could have
killed with the punishment okay still
alive
[Music]
running through the class frames running
through the flash frames oh the okay
butterflies
oh
cd3s are coming out already yeah
just harassing the legs
are we seeing it again it looks like we
could have another dc oh but we've
switched immediately to the backup do
you guys see this level of production
you didn't miss anything
i feel like production need their own
set of commentators talking about how
good they are that's absolutely crazy
thank you guys i stuck there on the
switch
oh down four two
one
i'm back again the elbow nice stuck on
switch one
raise
this is one way to bring it back this
won't be dead but this is a nice start
what's the mixer you'll go in surely
wow big 442 there by mob
[Music]
gonna be just doing nothing right now
let me play in his face this is what he
likes
not gonna switch one this time
that's all
down back four
there we go
nice g clef canon
just shy of rage right now there is back
four
big challenge rage available 20 seconds
left
that didn't hit okay let's be honest mob
even you have to want to say that didn't
touch that range oh that didn't hurt
didn't hit that did not hit
did not don't believe that
um but anyway
great starting here replay so who knows
we'll find out i think they both press
buttons at the same time yeah that's why
it hit what probably happened there is
uh
uh bombing probably pushed the button
and when you push the button second it
extends your heart box
so things that look like they shouldn't
hit they hit that's probably what
happened now unfortunate um for um
bumblebee but you know that's mob going
up first game looking strong and even
even though we said it could have been a
throwaway pick but josie didn't look
terrible you know he might stick to the
final round could have gone all the way
so yeah i'd i liked that i did i
actually don't like the josie it might
even be a counterfeit forum
for
mob because you play bomb he's played
can you mix it the whole time these two
have probably played back and forth a
lot of times someone in chat said
earlier that um
uh mob actually taught bumblebee so you
know that's um all right there's gonna
be history between these two so maybe
josie is the character that normally
works out them when they play and maybe
just struggles with kuni mitsu
interesting interesting i think well the
other thing that we maybe didn't call
out enough there was that they got their
under the infinite stage straight off
the bat
which obviously helped mob uh big time
uh so yeah i wouldn't forgive him
picking josie again he was much better
than i expected him to be and it didn't
look like he wasn't sure of himself yeah
he's come with it again
not a bad decision
yeah it's interesting because in some in
some ways this is great for lars on one
axis because he can just carry from
tekken 2 to tekken tag tournament five
uh all the way across but then on the
other axis it's a very very short range
stage and if he keeps him in within that
range
he's gonna lock down a lot of that carry
you really escalate a lot of the seconds
that last carries you through fight
[Music]
that fall
oh nice cd3 gets the card
great start here by bubbly warbong goes
nice he stays ducking but no launch
let's finish the string this should be
the round nice wait for this game
fight
star here by mumbling
forget the count here very nice
this does so much we going all the way
back we'll get in the windows that mob
knew that was coming as well
hey start here mob this is definitely
his round no way in hell that he loses
this round absolutely impossible for mob
to lose this round of tekken in front of
him right now all he needs is one more
hit and mob is going to win this
completely unlosable round that there is
with the downfall one
you are trying so hard to curse yourself
aren't you i'm not
four point two staying obvious right
nice to pull over kick
well one thing we're not seeing from
obviously we're fun isn't the best right
now not getting full launches on things
making things work punishment is really
lacking right now but it doesn't matter
because he's still ahead
not right now though down forward four
nice there from bumble um
it's all good stepping but you've also
got to pull the trigger when it's your
turn
oh
i wasn't confident that that was going
to be the punish there
someone for the sway back in step and
that's the fourth one plus two team from
nowhere nice while 72-1
great breakthrough
oh
final round again for the second time
the josie even though he's he's not
i mean i say he hasn't he didn't win the
first game josie's looking strong right
now and staying very competitive
fully agree fully agree
again it look it looks like two people
who know each other who have similar
timing yeah that was a great duck there
by bombay though but no messes up the
combo
that one gets the count hitting nice
slides into some stuff
doesn't pull the trigger on the online
special great duck on two or you don't
see that very often
cd3
rage available for bumblebee
standing three two finishes the string
and down forward four bumble bee we're
all tied up now in the josie not looking
too bad right now
not at all not at all and that down foot
four was so smart it just locked down
every single option he had yeah whether
he you know i've noticed that he if he's
going to go for the lightning screw he's
going to do it in his own zero health it
doesn't really matter anyway and of
course he had the rage drive but it
locked down at every single option
uh so yeah great great finish that route
and yeah as you say it's actually
looking like a pretty good choice
that's the thing as well you know when
two people who play all the time in this
situation you're going to see the weird
things you're going to see some things
certainly you're not used to because
they're just so used to each other um
like they just they do weird things you
don't expect this they're going to throw
out some random which you don't expect
people to throw out and then you know
they end up just you know
winning because of it so that's just
what happens you have to start hiding
some secret straps when you play against
someone you're so close to
um but yeah josie you know that is the
the name of the day right now it's also
characters you don't see very often if
we're being honest you know josie's
really a lot of josie players have just
sort of moved on you know when it came
to season four you know they don't
really play the character anymore you
know playing other characters chicken
mara for example in the best josie's in
the world one of the best in europe you
know switched to marduk and lydia now um
you know players like poke chopper
playing uh negan and and [ __ ] rum
just uh blackbeard playing you know
lydia and konimitsu now you know josie
serena as well yeah josie just kind of
hold him by the wayside right now um but
yeah just it brings to the infinite
stage very smart
um it's where he is the best uh
uh from what we've seen throughout the
day it's where he's home
and i just get the thing this could just
go back and forth again we could be
playing stage ping pong
it's got to be siberia
i'm just thinking you just think about
the location again
oh yeah i want to go there looks good
for one plus two to start the round
cd to the mix there from bomb will be
what a start
less than ten seconds in and mob is
already in rage
nice g clef though that's something he's
doing very often down for one it's g
club cannon and there you go
throws that again
oh right now he's not broken his ball be
throwing this round away
okay that is insane downfall one into g
clef cannon is literally one mob that
entire round but i just thought oh great
punish there for bumby by the way um a
reason why josie's getting this match up
basically all of lars's lows are going
to be launched punishable
yeah of course um
that was such an emphatic start to that
last round they did with a loss that was
crazy
he just downpoured one into g clef
cannon like he's just not
he's just not pushing the right buttons
oh big down two gets the counter and the
pickup as well
this isn't going to be dead is he going
to use rage though yes he is oh he is
interesting choice sure i mean surely
he's going to leave him with he's not
going to be dead he has too much health
what's the follow-up though oh great
patience
excellent patience there from bumblebee
to make the the garb kick whiff and just
a simple punch of downfall for that
spacing was absolutely superb
cd3 mind your ankles
there's a lot of momentum going back and
forth here yeah
great little harry there excellent
scouting by bumblebee
[Music]
bongos doesn't work out this time but
nice ford one plus two what's the
follow-up mix-up
okay new race drive
keychart
[Music]
everything right now
great block on the floor forward four
bumblebee is active
that is a hell of a read he was
shuffling right up in his grill that was
a crazy crazy read oh and a big counter
here to start off right now for
bumblebee we criticize the josie pick
out first but it's doing so much damage
with a huge crush
this is gonna put bubble uh mob in rage
oh
but can't get the combo he thought it
was a regular magic four it was a float
race drive spent
now pulled one nice g cliff cannon
interrupted 4.43 the plus reigns rage
available
one one we'll do it again surely he's
drive forward four into switch three the
first time he's done that load the
entire set
that that is that is tekken that is
tekken jesus jesus louise
we have just gone from the slowest game
of tekken i have ever seen in my life at
the start of this tournament honestly i
thought i could take a nap at one point
and then that game was absolutely insane
the adrenaline i was feeling watching
that game the momentum and the way it
was shifting these guys played so fast i
just love that these guys are capable of
switching gears so heavily the fact that
bumblebee opened up so fast and those
crashed as twos were all hitting that
was just great awareness and realizing
where he wants the duck also great reads
on the lows you know that'll find that
round before the final four four three
that was an excellent block there by
bumblebee um
i i was gonna criticize him for being
too passive before going into that game
but now he's just decided i don't get to
i don't deserve to criticize him
apparently with the way he just sped
through that round so you know this is
potential final game right now mob
i think that's the first time we've seen
him lose on the internet stage here
today well he lost earlier to greetings
but that's
not like that you know like that was
just
he just looked like he was getting
completely outplayed by anything and the
fact that he saved the the switch three
for then the first time he's used that
low the entire the first time he's used
a low out of switch the entire set just
so smart and then we move into bomby's
potential final game tournament game
here for bombay if he wins this he'll be
the toc eu east champion but mob
definitely has something to say about
that
no doubt whatsoever starts with bolt
smash doesn't get anything off it goes
in the cheek clef he's got a loss off
that
definitely
especially when he does it off down
forward one i mean bumpy just isn't
playing around it correctly but there
again another cd2 and no he wanted to
keep the tail spin there i respect a
nice punisher on the three two nice
punishment on the ukemi great low parry
this could be the start of something
spence tell spin early this time gonna
break the no he wanted to break the
balcony so unfortunately whether we're
punished that could have been huge
three three
all this way back oh but it was a down
jab so it didn't work
round two
fight
i need to be the class frames the plus
frames
and then back four
g again down forward one time down
forward one g clef cannon he isn't ready
okay warbonne goes yeah one goes again
into the switch three this time
all this pressure
it's threatening now
nice we're punished
mob in rage
great low power patience a great low
parry but he wanted a big combo there to
kill
regular broken three on back
back one big and that's guaranteed if
you back for a bomb we needed to stay
down and mob has finally got some
control back
he has and he's doing it on not an
infinite stage yeah stealing it stealing
his turn back so to speak
nice punishment for two
before we get into switch one
both of them percy close to that balcony
we'll crash down football big low nice
blocking
and the ford ford four he can't block it
this time and we are going to a final
game right now and bumblebee has a huge
decision ahead of him right now
you know you the josie has done so well
that game before josie isn't it was so
good it just just really locked down mob
he's shown why the character is good you
know and that's the thing all basically
all those that lars does are launched
punched for josie so it is a smart pick
and it's really paying dividends with
punisher before one plus two is on point
but
is it time to bring out kenny mitsui
because this is this is it this is the
reset or the tournament on the line here
they say so tech in his chest on speed
and uh wouldn't it be the ultimate
checkmate to actually go back to an
infinite stage
okay which i'm talking to on a private
line don't pull faces whilst i'm
commentating you said that who says
tekken is check on speed
that's the first time i've heard that
it used to be on tekken zaibatsu until
they got rid of it and they replaced it
with discord i'm not even gonna go into
that it's some boomer reference okay
then
i'm too young to understand apparently
uh as you keep reminding me i honestly i
don't think the infinite stage would be
a bad pick it would be the ultimate
check mate if he actually beat him again
on the infinite stage but there are
other options i think just complete this
set with josie just just see it out see
it out
i mean that's the one thing and then
it's you know what what is the stage
pick you know you know we know mob loves
the infinite but you did win on the
internet stage just uh just before that
you know you kind of dominated him so
it
character on stage it's your choice
bumblebee what are you doing
he's gone for the infinite himself
i like it i like it
this is the ultimate baller decision i
love it i absolutely love it
here we go
get ready guys this could be your final
game of the day
cd3
this is a great start here from
bumblebee but he needs more
nice block but no punishment to switch
through
oh no he's just too many wrists and
that's not even natural i don't know
what bumble's doing he's falling apart
right now no punish there raise jabs
already
it's just looking a bit desperate right
now for bomb will be no resources for
the comeback
the only reason he's got his time he's
got 30 seconds to do this he doesn't
need to rush it running three
and the forward forward for again i have
to respect mob as well for doing that
after the way it was blocked
emphatically in the two games beforehand
okay but big counter to start with
[Music]
g-clef cannon
[Music]
patience here oh even on like
all the positions
okay
[Music]
dude he knows not to finish at that time
not broken and the shoulder of the back
throw mob one round away from resetting
the bracket here today
and this is five rounds straight enough
for mob he has all of the momentum in
his favor
nice power power crush wood board two
look at this momentum now oh
oh no
punish
not at all there
if bomb will even let him get back in
with that move
give him a rope if bumblebee loses this
round he only has himself to blame
running three
fully agree
he's got rage yeah some static movement
here one forward one plus two could
change this entire game
razor i've spent
race drive spent on the other side now
smash
cd3
oh the down four of range
12 seconds eleven
standing three the keep out oh and look
at that look the cheeky low there from
mob as he now resets the bracket and i
have to say momentum is all in mob's
favor right now yeah you can't doubt it
the foot sees as well the spacing on
that there's no doubt that one here that
was just absolutely perfectly spaced
yeah and that's what you get when you
play a character as much as he clearly
has
that's just so scary when you think
about it because mob that was six rounds
straight the walls weren't played in the
infinite he's really nullified it and
now
this is a tough choice now for bumblebee
because josie worked that well at some
point you know jose was doing a job
then when he went to the the if you can
go to what i'm hearing is that mob does
very well against kinimitsu he knows the
character very well so that's why he
might also shy away from picking the
character by there's a time to pick the
maintenance now you gotta just try it
see how it goes
i don't know i'm i'm this
please i'm with you i'm with you i mean
i actually
i think for many players
when you switch between characters
there's almost a round or two you may
chuck away getting yourself reacquainted
with the spacing and the movement and
the
uh the the natural fundies of the
character you're using and you kind of
can give away a round or two in in the
exchange
so if he's going to make that decision
to change i feel like he should do it
sooner rather than later
no he's sticking with the jersey is
committed i think one
he had a plan
uh he he had a plan going to josie like
i mentioned earlier all the low pack all
the lows basically all last is loads of
punishment for josie a smart decision
and two someone's say people are telling
me that you know mob does very well
against kuninitsu so he just wants to
say that stay away from that
the beautiful you mother cereal oh a
magic fall straight off the bat
okay oh he could have some crazy stuff
there in the back though didn't commit
to it
could have had a launch
it's the wall splat knife picks up off
the wall i'm gonna break the balcony yes
he is i don't know if this is dead
though
cd three one more here does it a down
four nice ends it with a safe love round
two
fight
nice duck
full string hits again i don't know why
it isn't natural i don't know what
bumpy's doing
it's the same with g clef he's just
getting hit by the full thing
[Music]
again doesn't finish the last hit though
punish that no that could have been
launched for josie that could have been
launched for josie oh
boy
those were two launch opportunities that
went as a ride there for bumblebee
nice low parry
how far is he going to take him
very nice indeed
that's a big chunk for a low parry
[Music]
cd3 is getting started
ah but this the down bell count here
oh that was just complete mix there by
mob new exact ability to adjust
when when he doesn't get the juggle that
he he should be getting because of the
wall weird angles all of that stuff is
so good
nice just die stuck
just cools out the magic four gonna be a
sidewall though
oh my goodness just mob is completely
mixing bumpy right now he knows exactly
when he wants to duck
carries to the wall as well
cd3
this can be the start big power crush
guaranteed pump
i mean this is a great start right now
for mob
racket reset
and he goes up and uh what's that
i know i know bumblebee got around there
but without that round they'll be like
nine rounds straight
yeah it was dominant it was it was
dominant i think
i think ultimately
his mob's ability to just convert any
unusual random situation that you get in
a 3d fighting game to the maximum damage
that he can possibly get and the mix-up
is just too good right now
um and so a lot of that will come down
to the fact that he's clearly played
probably 10 20 000 games of player
matches with this character he's seen
every single scenario with his character
with his character
big body small bodies weird stage
interactions and he's just able to
convert every single one of them
yeah i do think if there's a time to
pull out kidding me to us now
yeah it feels like mob is now prepared
it feels like he's got everything done
he's he's warmed up into the set
uh winning the infinite winning on the
wall stage like it doesn't matter to him
right now so
um i'm hoping that that i feel like now
is the time to put out a commit suit at
least give the main character a shot
you know because josie has just now been
knocked down
i feel like he knows what he's doing
i can't think of much he hasn't tried
already with josie now that's that's
that's one of the main reasons why i
would say switch okay he's gone back to
hammerhead
you have to respect it
they must have played a lot for him to
stay away from playing his main so much
i'll be i've been told that mob is very
very very good against khmer so so he's
ready he knows what he has to do
um
i don't know how i feel about this
though
[Music]
nice block of the wall bonkers and the
punish
both of them showing great defense being
20 seconds of them both pressing buttons
and they haven't lost a lot of a lot of
health really
okay this is a great start right now for
bumblebee that's the float though and
that was we've seen so many crazy stuff
in this there was lost
all right where's dress spent
it's a good manager
[Music]
this is the string and oh that was just
a complete mix up there but bumblebee
guess is wrong and mob is just storming
through this reset right now
he's five rounds away from winning the
whole tournament oh that was so nice and
the set up oh
that punishes the art block could have
been more
all right let's pull over the kick
on back
trade which one gets the count here very
nice
now he's got some pressure he needs this
oh guaranteed follow up there nice bum
will be on the board again
okay he stopped the bleed that was very
important it's looking like it was
starting to get away from him
max punished there that is -14
mob was ready
and he gets a nice chunk and a throw
after very nice and deep let's punish
he's to use this wall
on back cross frames
brace ben 4.43
doesn't use the plus right
again though
i have to respect mob's usage of that
low considering how it lost him around
earlier he just hasn't been deterred no
not at all not at all and to to give
away the frames and just stand there
after and see what he does very very
smart very nice there from bumblebee the
regular broken
oh converts it again he's seen it all
the keychain
rage available for both now one two four
no dark
war bongos nice block
race spent
oh my goodness 20 seconds they're both
on such low health downfall rage
oh oh he's getting
three
poor choice harvey just felt like he was
going to go over standing through there
probably you could just feel it i wasn't
sure
of the art blasts that's punishing cd3
though
this is crucial this is either two zip
or one all yeah this is a very important
game right now
i'm back
one two four nice no ducks though by mob
he needs to start ducking one two snails
but needs to do more
or two
finishes the string again bumblebee
could take this round rage span and nice
was going to respect the unblockable
atoll x and hot kick there from bombing
were tied up he is not out of this yet
why did she cry like that
i'm not gonna even spend the rest of
commentary deciding about what's the
best character pick or stage pick i'm
done
i'm not doing it anymore
that was um
i don't know i know we want to see i
feel like the queen of myths to pick
here but josie's staying alive jose
still doing the job that he needs it to
do but
you know that was with the walls in play
now now mob is going to go back to his
traditional i like no walls there's
going to be no walls in place josie
loses all that damage that she gets with
it all the wall carry it doesn't mean
anything
um but we'll just see it was seeing some
great outplay here for more but
bumblebee is staying alive that hot kick
but that was just that was really good
there just the awareness and space of
mine that even a defensive situation be
ready to push a button like that to
counteract he was ready so that was a
good job
um and we're all tied up after the
bracket reset so you know bumblebee
keeping this close mob isn't going to
storm through this one today
no not at all and that that that hopkin
wasn't like it was a panic button like
he's i don't think he's pressed that all
game like that was a clear active
decision to to interrupt it and it was
clutch especially after that round
before where they both
oh my god that was so close i nearly
gave me a heart attack there's the
infinite sure
smart decision is we know it's what it's
known for
it is indeed had a very very very high
success rate with this stage
watch your ankles watch your ankles
again this time he blocks it nice punish
[Music]
nice the warbonkers spaced it correctly
that's guaranteed of only the low hits
momentum swings once again it's a
bumblebee and that is such a bold
decision
not going to get much on an infinite
stage of low parry but that is such a
confident move
nice no that's not the punishment minus
12.
[Music]
gonna be trying to force something here
but the g-clef kind of stops him
completely
punish that
[Music]
nice dark
i'm broken
[Music]
i'm just stuffing him right now rage
drive
cd3
stepping oh double what's going on here
standing three and just like that bumpy
one more round he goes up two one over
mob he looked he looked almost defeated
after the bracket reset but it's not
done in the back
in harada's name did he win that round i
i don't get it i don't get it that was
so good
i think i think we might see mob
panicking a bit i think if the other one
he tried to orbital that didn't work out
93.
okay nice guess the launch is big here
for mob needs this round
oh and running three just beating the
cd3 that's a huge statement it's such a
beautiful wedding three as well
nice duck
very nice
i've never seen that
before great low parry by bumblebee but
no rage so no extra damage does he stop
him before the rage yeah but
inadvertently did
oh the new rage driver that's just just
people just aren't ready to see that
yeah i feel like
yeah that new rage drive out of silent
entry
doesn't get you chunks but it's good end
again great block there on the cd3
is mob gonna make this comeback it was
looking like he was down and out but
it's completely ready right now i'm back
two four
challenge
and we just have raised there it is
suddenly where's your health bar gone
there it is the full crouch low and mob
is now
one more game and he is your evil
stephen
sorry your evo eu east champion will
also be your toc eu e's champion but
i've just been commentating mob too much
recently
you just totally option selected
yourself it was fun
[Laughter]
what a player
too much um but yeah because this is
exactly what superhuman did he was the
evo eu west champion and then he went on
to win toc and it's looking like mob is
going to do the same thing and superman
also did that from this racket and the
same thing might happen here um but you
know i'm i'm really um
i'm really impressed by the way
bumblebee is playing with the josie
right now that we were both expecting a
switch at some point but sticking with
the josie playing well uh keeping it
competitive he could have won that game
there just came down to mob mob just
flicked the switch out of nowhere and it
just made things a lot more difficult
but i feel like you can still bring it
back
um
but yeah this is this could be the final
game if mob is uh
some point here
it's a legit josie i almost would feel
sad if he's changed now we're going to
find out very shortly
drum roll josie
okay
good choice good choice
and is this going to be our final game
of the tournament good boy these guys
are going to twist it again let's find
out i mean i like it i like it stuck
with the jersey all the way through i
had a game plan it's worked this far got
him this far but mob could end it all
right here right now
nice stuck
oh the full crowd swipes three in a row
into the g-clef cannon mob is on form
right now g-clef cannon again this is
gonna be the first round for lmg mob
i just took a sip from my drink and a
whole round went what the hell
and you see immediately bumby is trying
to counteract that aggression trying to
get something from his own start there
it is yeah the switch starts going but
oh gets floated when you try to do uh
board one plus two going to the wall as
well shoulder strap
no goes for the mixed up regular throw
broken
counter hit mob
okay but the gap three
we needed that so bad
harry just shot the wall
orbital
four four four three again since that
first time he hasn't blocked it again
but rage available for pokemon the rage
drive for bomb will be he stays alive
that was crucial he was nearly
fighting against game game set
tournament round now it's one all
as the momentum shifted in bumblebee's
favor big for one plus two to start off
with
one
[Music]
this is a great round right now for mob
has the live lead so much pressure
i'm beating rage running three two
good break
[Music]
oh no while setting two into the back
stance
he needs to do so much now
oh this is the start though raised drive
guaranteed after that makes a full combo
to the wall makes up cd
the risk there from bumblebee he stays
alive and it all came from that forward
one plus two
that was a heroic comeback what a
comeback in conversion
how is he two rounds to one up after the
start of this game that's crazy
showed up
goes for the big low
[Music]
patience by bomb b cd3
[Music]
nice block on the wall one goes but
doesn't punish
nice patience
like four or four big range that's weird
punish finishes again that string and
just like that mob is on tournament
point with your toc eu east champion
now let's go again
bumblebee is being too passive right now
he's just watching mob he's watching mob
he's just watching him right now
needs to do something
on back regular throw broken
cd through great block bumblebee enrage
he gets him
what a way to end the tournament there
by a mob the air throw bumblebee wasn't
ready completely stylish exactly how you
want to end it stomps in him for good
measure and just like that mob is going
to be your toc eu east champion
i was enjoying that